so thanks for the um invitation
to present and and to the organizers for
setting up this this
nice event so i'll be talking about um
this new approach i should have
mentioned in in the title uh to some of
the square's lower bounds in particular
um over the hypercube um and so
fortunately
alfonso was about to not do this but
then at the very end
did me a favor and explain some of the
kind of
initial ideas but i will
just go over this quickly again and talk
about the the problem
setting i'll be interested in so the
basic
uh kind of class of problem i'll be
talking about is
this one which we've seen a couple of
times already so this is maximizing
um a quadratic form with respect to some
matrix but constrained
to the hypercube it's kind of a simple
model problem for
for combinatorial optimization
and in particular you know this being
this this uh
computational phase transitions uh
workshop i'll be i'll be looking at uh
situations where this coefficient matrix
is drawn randomly
so what kinds of distributions make
sense here there's one that we saw
already which is quite prominent and
kind of a natural choice if you just
think okay
i need a good well-behaved you know
simple
random symmetric matrix which is the
gaussian orthogonal ensemble
and so uh ahmed talked about this a
bunch in in his lecture this gives us
uh the solution to this problem up to
sine will be the ground state
of the uh sk model tim
can i uh briefly interject the your
zooms that
shows over your screen if there is a
chance to kill it
yeah oh okay sorry cool yeah i was
wondering if uh
can you see this little this
participants thing also that i'm no
we see your i see your full screen
perfectly well now so
okay um okay
let me know if there are any other uh
absolutely technical technical things
um so okay so if we plug in uh
the goe for w right we get this this
ground state of the
sk model this has been studied i'm not
giving uh
full references here but at great length
in statistical physics so
in particular one nice thing about
working with this model is that we know
very precisely um the the true
value of this so so this is this this
kind of approximate equality is
a concentration statement this is true
about the expectation
um so this will concentrate around
around this
1.5 ish value the parisi number
um so this was conjectured in the
physics literature and then proven
later by by mathematicians um so
maybe from kind of a more combinatorial
optimization point of view
a more natural model might be to take
a random graph laplacian in which case
what you're calculating here
is the the size of the largest cut in
your graph and
uh so then okay you you need kind of
some
underlying random graph distribution and
it turns out that
the the sort of most interesting scaling
is to take uh sparse
or or degree order constant uh random
graphs either regular
random graphs or the training will both
work
and then you'll get some kind of uh
different behavior
but so i'm going to talk about only the
problem
on the left uh this sk model but if you
happen to find uh the problem on the
right more natural
you might be comforted by knowing that
as the degree
grows the asymptotics of this max cut
model
actually sort of reduce to those of this
sk model so this is a result
of uh amir dumbo and uh andrea and
subhabrata
um that that shows that this this sort
of second order term and the degree
in the max cut model um actually the the
kind of coefficient there
is this this uh parisian number on the
left-hand side
in this limit and you can do similar
kinds of uh you know interpolations
between these things for
uh simple semi-definite programs and and
so
in in various senses these are closely
related so i'm going to take that as
justification for
for worrying about only the simpler uh
gaussian model
and and going forward with that but we
sort of expect that uh results about the
sk model you know should be
possible somehow to import to the the
graph models
so in any case uh what we'll be
interested in is okay this gives us the
true value
um all these classical results but what
about the sort of computational
costs of this kind of problem so
there are kind of two natural
computational tasks that you can set
yourself about this and one we heard
about already which is the the maybe the
more
immediate one which is finding an x a
good x
which achieves as close to the optimal
value as possible and there are various
kind of algorithmic ideas that make
sense here
and as ahmed mentioned there's this
result due to
andrea originally that
with some sort of variant of message
passing of amp you can get
uh sort of arbitrarily close to to this
optimal value
so this you know we we can think is is
more or less settled
um but what i'm going to talk about is
is this other
question of certification so here
instead of computing instead of taking
the matrix w
and computing a good x i want to compute
just a number the c of w
so that no matter what matrix you gave
me this is an upper bound so i want to
kind of trust the output of this
algorithm i take it as a certificate
hence the the name um on the the
quality of all possible solutions of all
possible x's
and so subject to that to this working
for all matrices w
under my particular distribution i want
to make this number as small as possible
right i want to
certify tight bounds on this
optimization problem
and typically uh the way that we do this
is with various kinds of uh convex
relaxation so i'll get back to this in a
minute but you can you can make lp
relaxations of this or sdp relaxations
or
whatever kinds of strategies you want
and so this talk is about
kind of what is how good can we make
these certification algorithms how do
they compare to search algorithms and
questions like that so among
certification algorithms there's kind of
a natural
initial choice which is a spectral bound
so how do we get the spectral band we
just take our problem
and we say forget everything special
about x forget all of this hypercube
uh nonsense and just remember that x
lies this hypercube lies on a sphere
just optimize over that sphere right and
that that
kind of bounds this by an eigenvalue
problem
right and so we get this kind of
spectral bound by the largest eigenvalue
of w
and i'll take my my goes maybe i should
have mentioned this earlier to
be scaled so that the largest eigenvalue
is uh approximately two
so i get this kind of bound and remember
the true value is like 1.5 n
right so this is a loose bound this is
this is not very good
and yet so as afonso mentioned at the
end and kind of the strategy as close to
what he was talking about
throughout his talk there's some sort of
indirect evidence
that uh this bound should be optimal
among
all polynomial time certificates so this
kind of very naive
bounding strategy we believe should be
actually the best
that uh that you can achieve by sort of
reducing this this
question to some sort of statistical
testing problem and arguing that that
testing problem is uh
is hard to solve that's roughly the
argument there so i'll give the citation
for where we did this earlier before
before this coloring paper
um in a second specifically for this
this
hypercube problem and actually so i'll
mention i mean the connection to
coloring is that a uh so in in the graph
setting right a
large cut is an approximate two coloring
a two coloring is a bipartition right a
large cut is kind of a nearby partition
so that's that's how that uh comes up as
a special case of these coloring results
so to summarize right let's let's
look at how how these search and
certification results compare to each
other so here
is the spectrum of the goe the way i'm
scaling it
there's the largest eigenvalue which is
approximately two
right and here's the true value of this
optimization problem
so if you ask about search algorithms
right the story of search
algorithms for this problem is a story
of like happy
progress towards the the best possible
result
you could expect right so here are a
bunch of kind of reasonable strategies
you could try i like to
you know point out there's this uh kind
of classic paper and and sort of spin
glass map of
eisenmann leibowitz and rural and they
actually uh
analyze without really caring about you
know algorithmic consequences
to quite natural um algorithms for
trying to find a good x so
rounding the the sort of top eigenvector
of the goe and some kind of greedy
um iterative algorithm so anyway so you
might think okay a random kind of uh
guess of x will get you basically zero
so this is all on the scale
i've kind of i'm renormalizing the
result of the algorithm by uh
by n right i'm dividing by n so random
guess will
is kind of zero on that scale these
other strategies kind of gradually
improve and then
this result of andrea tells you that you
can get sort of arbitrarily close to the
optimum
um in in polynomial time so so this is
all
great um on the other hand for
certification
right basically every algorithm is every
polynomial time algorithm is stuck
at this spectral uh threshold the
spectral barrier
right so so it seems that for all
polynomial time algorithms this gap
that i've marked with these arrows
between 1.5 and and 2
actually persists so here's kind of a
quick summary
of of what's been done about this so so
in the course of doing other things this
paper i think was mentioned already in
some of the other talks um but uh andrea
and uh subreddit analyzed uh the degree
two sos relaxation which is also this
goemon's williamson algorithm kind of
stp
um and showed that that this does know
better than than this
um largest eigenvalue so then um
alex alfonso and i gave this indirect
kind of reduction to statistical testing
that kind of argument
um in the second paper there were
two concurrent papers treating sos4 one
by
myself and alfonso and then the other by
uh siddhanth and
prasad and uh another student jeff shu
who's maybe
somewhere in the audience also and so
this was about a year ago
and then uh most recently and what i'll
be talking about now
is using um a somewhat different
approach so which is
sort of generalizing the our our method
for uh degree four
um i gave a degree six lower bound and
around the same time
another group um gave actually much
higher sos lower bounds
but using a different technique so i'll
still i'll talk about these kind of
um weaker results but that have some
some
technical uh differences that i think
are are interesting nonetheless
uh so any questions so far before i get
into these
sos specific things
i guess i actually can't see questions
in chat but only if people say something
no no no no just yet so keep going okay
great um so now
uh i'll start talking about okay how do
we actually prove lower bounds for this
particular semi-definite programming
hierarchy so here's a quick overview of
how we actually formulate these these
semi-definite programs so remember
here's our problem the first step is to
write it as a polynomial
optimization right so here i'm rewriting
my constraints
as a polynomial constraint so now i have
polynomial objective function polynomial
constraints and this is what i need to
to write
an sos sum of squares relaxation
so the basic kind of object involved i
won't talk about the kind of dual side
of this at all which is where the term
sum of squares
comes from but there's a reason for that
but i'll talk about this this
sort of primal viewpoint
so the basic object is is this thing
called a pseudo expectation which is
like an expectation
over uh distribution on the plus minus
one hypercube
but restricted to only satisfy
constraints
that concern low degree polynomials so
this is an operator on low degree
polynomials
which is linear has this normalization
constraint
is zero on the ideal generated by these
constraint polynomials
and has this positive semi-definiteness
property so this is quite close
to the the you know conditions that jess
listed out
the other day for the analogous local
statistics hierarchy
so to formulate the sos relaxations
uh we just uh sort of plug this in
you know we evaluate this on our
objective function
and now we optimize uh over all of these
pseudo expectations so for any actual
hypercube vector x
right just uh the the operator that
evaluates a polynomial at that point is
a pseudo expectation
so this optimization includes
all evaluations at hypercube points but
it also includes more
stuff and so it's a relaxation it's an
upper bound and you so you can rewrite
this as a semi-definite program in a
certain way where the last constraint
here the positivity constraint becomes
positive semi-definiteness i'll say
something about this
in a second and so you can solve these
efficiently for
d constant or 2d constant
and these these are powerful relaxations
compared to other relaxations right so
here i'm saying for this particular
problem they don't work
but uh you know compared to other lps
compared to other sdps there are various
ways to formulate these hierarchies
and in various senses this is kind of
the most powerful thing we know
so this is really kind of a high
standard for
showing that these things don't work is
a high standard for lower bounds for
certification
so in our case to prove a lower bound
what do we need to do right we want to
show that this
thing does no better than uh the
spectral bound right so we want an
equality like this
and so to do that right we need to build
one of these these points that has a
large value on the objective function
one of these pseudo expectations and
uh in particular this amounts to having
this this degree two
pseudo moment matrix so the expectation
xx transpose
uh being sort of highly correlated in
matrix
inner product with my coefficients with
my goe matrix
right but the so the diagonal entries of
this thing are all one because
x i squared equals one is a constraint
right and this is a psd matrix so it's
traces n it's psd
and its inner product with this other
matrix is about n times the largest
eigenvalue
right so most of its sort of quote
unquote spectral mass
needs to be aligned with the top
eigenvectors
of the the goe those top eigenvectors
span
a uniformly random low dimensional
subspace
so basically what has to happen i mean
this is assuming a little bit more
symmetry than necessary
but uh roughly what what needs to happen
is that this matrix should be
a rescaling of a projection to a
uniformly random
low dimensional subspace of rn
and sort of the lower the smaller you
take that dimension the the better uh
the closer to
two to lambda max of w uh your bound
will get
so this is something like what we're
trying to do so let me talk about
how you know everyone else likes to
build these things and then i'll talk
about how i'm suggesting that we might
think about building these things and
what the advantages of that might be
so the kind of standard strategy and
random problems and deterministic
problems
basically no matter what so this
includes pseudo calibration which which
just mentioned
various arguments based on symmetry and
i mean
really kind of the vast majority of
approaches
to sos that that i've seen is that you
look at the monomials
the the values of the pseudo expectation
on monomials you make some kind of
argument maybe it's it's about these
planted distributions maybe it's about
something else
and you guess what the value of these
things should be right so now you just
have a bunch of numbers
and if you did this correctly this will
satisfy all those linear constraints
um that the pseudo expectation has to
satisfy it'll satisfy the ideal
constraints it'll make the objective
uh objective function large and and so
on
right but now you know you look at this
and you have to you have to prove
this positivity constraint you have to
prove that this
object i was alluding to before the
pseudo-moment matrix is psd
and you have so you built this matrix as
a big like box of numbers
right there's no structure beyond box of
numbers built into it and you have to
show that it's psd and this is a very
hard
kind of technical thing lots of lots of
ink has been spilt
on on these arguments in sos literature
so briefly why is this so hard
so i mean the first reason i would say
is is again that we've built this matrix
in such a way
that we don't have a reason to really
expect
that it should be psd and so you know
the argument kind of has to be purely
technical we just look at what we got
out of our prediction and we figure out
some other reason why it's going to be
psd
and the the spectrum of this matrix and
and you know if you break it up into
little matrix pieces the spectrum of all
of those pieces
will have this multi-scale property
where so this is a picture of the you
know the kind of histogram of
eigenvalues of a typical thing that
comes up in this analysis
it has mass at many different kind of
separated powers of n
this is a caricature but you know
roughly speaking this is the idea
and their sort of total contribution to
let's say the trace
of your pseudo-moment matrix is roughly
is kind of comparable
um so so now you know maybe you have an
error term that is like uh this same
picture but let's say scaled down by one
over n or something
and you have a main term that's like
this picture and you're trying to
understand
the spectrum of the sum of them and
you're going to have to do you know this
this
kind of very tricky analysis of
understanding how
the bits of the spectrum at different
scales interact with one another and
sort of counter balance each other
and and things like that so so i mean
the the big picture um
difficulty is that you have you know
these structured matrices with this
complicated spectrum
and you're trying to argue for positive
semi-definiteness with some kind of
you know decomposition and you have to
do these these complicated sort of
balancing um arguments to to do this
okay so so this kind of approach makes
things difficult but i mean
they're to be fair there has been
tremendous success just kind of pushing
through these difficulties
um but so what i want to suggest is a
different
approach which which i'll call this
positivity first
approach where you build a positive
semi-definiteness into
your construction so your your pseudo
expectation is guaranteed to have
positivity
so the way that i uh formulate this is
by
saying okay i'm this this sort of uh
what what
sos people call a pseudo random variable
x to the tensor d
i'm going to introduce a genuine random
tensor
so this is uh this this g that plays the
role of that
of that sort of fictitious random
variable and i'm going to give it some
distribution it's going to be a random
tensor and my pseudo moments
will be the actual moments of this
random tensor
right and then i'll i'll kind of
constrain the distribution of that
tensor so that various
kind of stuff that i want is uh
satisfied so
in particular right i need the left-hand
side of this equation that i wrote to be
invariant under permuting all of these
indices of s and t
together right which is would be kind of
surprising for something of the forum on
the right hand side but at least i can
make this a symmetric tensor
right that'll satisfy some of these uh
symmetries
right i can i can force some
normalization constraints so this is
really just kind of
miming the sos constraints on this
tensor
i can say that when an index is repeated
right because x i
squared equals one there's this
backwards compatibility so here i'm
writing s
is i'm thinking of as a multi-set
because it's a this is a symmetric
tensor
when an index is repeated then i should
kind of revert to the
value that i had two tensors ago
in x tensor d minus two or it's it's
it's surrogate
um and then i need x to look like it's
supported
on this uh random uh random low
dimensional subspace
right so here x occurs in this big
tensor as
what you get when you freeze all but one
index of this big you know think of the
tensor as a cube
and i freeze all but one axis and i let
the last one vary
that vector that i formed that way has
to lie in this in this small subspace
and so subject to these things i take
this tensor to be as random as possible
so the way
or you know one way to achieve this that
makes it possible to do some
calculations
is to start with uh kind of the you know
the the nice
gaussian symmetric tensor kind of the
generalization of the goe
there's a unique uh orthogonally
invariant gaussian symmetric tensor
and uh and just condition on these
properties so on the at least on
on the linear ones of these properties
and then there's another kind of little
scaling detail to achieve the remaining
properties but that's that's the basic
spirit of this and it turns out that
with some more heuristic kind of
approximations you can do these
calculations
and you know approximately and if you
set up the approximations the right way
so there's again some kind of nuance
there
you actually get something that uh has
this symmetry that that
that these moments on the on the left
only depend
on the the total on all of the indices
occurring across
s and t but not how they're partitioned
into into s t
and there's a sort of diagrammatic
interpretation of this so here's the
result for uh
degree four which is from uh our paper
with afonso
so here m uh is this degree two part or
the
the sort of rescaled projection matrix
and we get
a sum over forests on four vertices
which looks like this and so here the
leaves are the
the labels are labeled by s and t
and the internal vertices are things
that you contract over
with uh picking up kind of entries from
m so this is sort of like a tensor
network or a trace diagram
if people are familiar with those things
from physics literature
it's also sort of like a graphical
matrix from sos literature but not not
not exactly and it turns out
that this uh so the coefficients of
these things are such that you will
always satisfy these ideal constraints
so if
an index is repeated here um then
one of these forests will kind of give
the the sort of
main contribution and then the other
ones will have some cancellation among
them so here i'll go quickly but you can
uh you can check that there's some uh
cancellation in these error terms that
makes the
the kind of excess in here small and so
you have this approximate ideal
constraint due to the coefficients these
forests have
and similarly even if like let's say all
of these indices are equal then all of
these are sort of main terms they all
contribute significantly but there are
three
terms contributing one here and then the
last one where there's only one term in
this sum that matters
and so this this term contributes minus
two and so you have approximately a
pseudo expectation of
uh x i to the fourth is approximately
one and
in general even for higher degrees the
coefficients that come out of this
calculation
are so they have an interpretation as a
mobius function of a certain partial
ordering of force so this is some
you know whatever technical thing but
it's its consequences that these kinds
of cancellations always happen for any
degree for any combination of repeated
uh indices etc right so
this kind of combinatorial relationship
between this construction
of the surrogate tensor and the mobius
function
ensures that that this will always uh
work out
okay so finally in my in my last moments
let me actually state
some results that this gives you so it
doesn't work as well as you might hope
it works really well in in a sort of
trivialized situation where instead of a
random low rank
projection matrix if i settle for a
random high rank projection matrix just
as kind of a toy model
this does nothing about the sk model it
probably doesn't even really say
anything terribly interesting about
um kind of sos integrality gaps but it's
just a model for you know does this work
to extend some matrices
then you can build uh these pseudo
expectations of diverging
degree that extend these high rank uh
random projection matrices
for the sk model you can kind of hack
things a little bit
and so in particular this lets you
improve from the previous degree 4
special case which has some
even kind of further structure that
makes it sort of easy to deal with by
hand
to uh degree six and uh
and then there are some difficulties in
term that are related
it seems like to some of the
approximations you make in this kind of
conditioning
this tensor calculation that stopped you
from going further but really what i
want to emphasize
is that there's something kind of new i
think driving these proofs
which is that there are these
combinatorial relationships between how
you calculate these conditional
distributions
and uh getting out on the other end
after all of these calculations
um the this this mobius function that
ensures the ideal constraint so the
conditional distribution and this whole
kind of
gram matrix construction ensures
positive semi-definiteness
and the the mobius function on the other
side ensures the ideal constraint so
there's a kind of combinatorial reason
why it's possible
to satisfy both of these um at the same
time and this technique seems to kind of
make this um you know make this more
prominent so i think it would be very
interesting
uh to see how this this whole story
works out in
other problems where people have proved
sos lower bounds already with other
methods
um okay thank you hopefully i'm not
too far over time thank you
for very nice talk uh so
maybe one or two short questions uh
and and then we will have to resume in
10 minutes uh
for the last talk of today so any
questions
so tim can i ask one question
i guess one question in two parts um so
one is um so the the degree two
construction that we have it sort of i
mean i guess
these are very spectral right so i was
wondering if these sort of degree four
and degree six constructions that you do
if they if you expect them to depend
very crucially on the gaussianity or do
you expect these to work
for general beginner matrices so and
and secondly so yeah sorry go ahead and
secondly i was just wondering
what happens if you change your ensemble
in the sense that
if you create an ensemble where you know
you have your
eigenvalues and then you have a
separated eigenvalue away from the bulk
and then your orthogonal matrices are
hard then for these problems would the
refutation problem behave very
differently
i guess these were the two things i was
wondering about so
okay so the second question sounds
challenging but the first question
i i can say something uh maybe more
satisfying about so here
this is the result of this calculation
for uh degree four
so um you can really imagine starting
with
any uh psd matrix any any degree two
uh sort of sdp witness m
and just applying this construction once
you have derived it
right so this does this only depends on
this uh sort of
low dimensional projection matrix that
you seek
to extend to higher degree bounds
and in fact the proof of this gives you
some way you know if you just follow
this construction you forget about all
the other motivation
then it suggests a uh
a big polynomial basis in which you can
write
the pseudo moments that
[Music]
at least deals with this kind of
multi-scale issue so it gives you a
pseudo-moment matrix where everything is
happening kind of on the constant scale
and you can try to either follow the
same analysis
or adjust things as as needed to prove
that that's psd but that in any case is
much easier than kind of what you would
be doing
otherwise so for example i think
something like this should work for like
if you plug in this
i don't know this this gaussian wave uh
construction that works for uh
deregular yeah graph laplacians or
whatnot and maybe even
so like in in the paper i give some just
general constraints on m
such that this works now the only
situation where i
uh really know exactly how to verify
them is for this random
projection matrix but i think in
principle you know something similar
should be workable otherwise
if if you're um if m is not
close to a um
just a rescaled low rank projection
matrix which i think
maybe covers the second part of the
question
then some of those conditions some of
the kind of errors that crop
up i think might become much uh
harder to bound at least at a technical
level if not
just becoming actually too large so this
is really the the level of
specialization is to kind of
lifting these generic projection
matrices um
so let's let me suggest that we wrap up
the official part of the
of the talk and q a and thank you for
the speaker
uh and uh meanwhile we are feel free to
continue
uh informally we're gonna resume in six
minutes with floor and stock